erdogan calls
on biden to reverse calling mass
killings of armenians a genocide this is
an nbc story
biden's historic declaration on saturday
has infuriated
turkey which has said the announcement
has opened a deep wound in relations
ankara turkish president recap taipei
erdogan called on president joe biden to
immediately reverse his declaration that
the 1950 massacres of armenians and
ottoman empire constituted genocide a
move he said was upsetting
and diminished bilateral ties biden's
historic declaration on saturday as
infuriated we know that the nato
ally in his first comments his biden's
statement erdogan said the wrong step
would hinder ties and advise the united
states to look in the mirror
adding turkey still sought to establish
good neighborly ties with armenia
the u.s president has made baseless
unjust untrue remarks about the sad
events that took place
in our geography over a century ago
erdogan said after a cabinet meeting and
repeated a call for
turkish and armenian historians to form
a joint commission
to investigate the events i hope the u.s
president will turn back from his wrong
step as soon as possible
if you say genocide then you need to
look at yourself in the mirror making an
evaluation the native americans i don't
i don't even need to mention
uh them what happened is clear he said
in reference to the treatment
of native americans by european settlers
while all these truths are out there you
cannot pin the genocide
accusations on the turkish people do you
have any strong opinions on this
yourself i'm just curious what you got
to say people okay
i'm kidding so do you have anything on
that or no i just i wanted to
obviously get your opinion on this well
i think just stating facts
a million armenians were killed
by on the uh was by the ottoman empire
in uh 1915 and obviously working for
a an armenian a syrian middle eastern
iranian
and my friend tigran and morale i've
learned to understand this and
being a jew uh whose great
aunts and uncles and great-grandparents
were killed in the holocaust
anytime you hear the word genocide or
holocaust it brings up a sore subject
so i know it's a touchy subject for all
armenians
and this is actually whether you're a
fan of biden or not something that i
i would assume you applaud yeah well
i i did a video about it and i said you
know kudos to them for doing it because
this
is a nato this is a this is a country
that's part of nato turkey is and this
is a country that's got
u.s military bases there that we kind of
need a couple air force bases yes
and this is a country that is the most
powerful military in the middle east
this is a country
that is uh both close to russia and
close to u.s is this going to push them
to get closer to russia the good news is
turkey still needs america it relies on
america for their commerce for their
business and
within turkey there are people in turkey
that are glad this took place
and they publicly talked about it and
erdogan's tried to silence them but
there's a community that's saying let's
just get out there and say
we did this and let's get it over with
so this is not a good place right now
for erdogan but let me give you what if
let me give you whatever what was that
movie that uh that was christian promise
promise phenomenal crime the promise or
coriander
the type of core you know he spent 100
million and i think the movie
didn't make any money but it wasn't a
goal of his to make money he just wanted
to make a very good movie christian
great actors if you've never seen it
it's fantastic but here's the biggest
what if what if biden turns on this you
what if
biden takes you know because sometimes
biden gets up and says something and
then aoc says something
it's like well we do have to kind of
change our position they are kind of
right and then he backtracks
if he does that that's a different story
do i think it's going to happen i don't
think that's going to be taking place
for him to backtrack but i also don't
think erdogan is done with
i don't think erdogan is done with i
don't think erdogan's going to sit here
and accept this
you have to understand if this gets all
the way to the top
and it's official what comes next is
reparations
and reparations in a genocide just like
germany had to pay it's like comps you
know how
you buy a house and you say this house
worth six hundred thousand dollars
the guy says no this is a 750 house show
me the cops they pulled three houses
next to you that just sold for 750 and
the house is one of them was smaller
than yours guess what
this is a hundred fifty thousand dollars
it's not a six hundred thousand dollars
then the buyer says okay fine i'll pay
you 750 right
when it comes down to events like this
holocaust
you know the cambodian genocide the
armenian
genocide the assyrian genocide the greek
genocide done by the ottoman empire
there's going to be some comps being
made and when these armenian folks who
are working at dc make these comms
this is not going to be a 50 billion
dollar reparation this is not going to
be a 100 billion dollar reparation
this is going to be a massive number
that turkey is going to be forced to pay
that's going to take them decades to pay
maybe 50 years to pay
won't be a small chunk of change it'll
be close to a trillion dollars i believe
the number is going to be a big number
for them to pay so turkey doesn't
want that to happen all the proof is now
coming out and if that takes place
this will not only be a good look
worldwide for turkey this will not be a
good look for turkey when it comes down
to their pockets
and the pockets is what they're also
worried about tremendously
history pride pocket all that's going to
come together
as armenians are going to go to dc next
saying now that you call this a genocide
here's what comes next so then they're
going to be pushing to
support a certain amount of you know
because they are nato ally
all this stuff it won't be pretty the
next two three four five years is going
to be very very strong negotiations
and uh i don't know how it's going to
end i don't know how it's going
why what why did biden do this what what
we're here in incentives and motivation
for
doing this especially within his first
hundred days yeah
he had to know he was going to face
backlash he had to have counsel that
said look
if you do this especially within your
first hundred days you're going to get
pushed back by erdogan
they're a nato ally why did he do this
yeah i mean uh first of all who does
this help republicans or democrats
process it that way you already know the
answer exactly
obviously he's not going to do this that
hurts this helps democrats or
republicans
who does it help you say democrats okay
tell me why
well i don't think biden is going to do
anything to to help republicans
okay but i mean i don't know you
probably have a difference you're ready
for this
no one's talking about this part here
here's what here's what it is
um are there more turkish americans or
armenian americans
hello or more turkish way more turkish
americans okay it's about 5x the number
some stage 3 some say 7. let's say it's
5x more
how many turkish americans are offended
i would assume a good amount okay right
he just lost them
which means if it's mathematically
republicans won because
if you won say 200 000 armenian votes
you may have lost 600 000 turkish votes
turks now may sit there and say it was a
democrat who passed the armenian
genocide
armenians are going to say what it was a
democrat who passed the armenian
genocide so armenians are going to vote
even some are going to flip and they're
going to go from republican democrat and
they're going to say what
see here's why i'm going to vote for who
by the way because you know our meaning
grandmas mothers are going to say
the republicans could never do this at
democrats so that's the part right
and turkish are going to say i told you
republicans were on our side
like that that's kind of how this
stuff's going to be because most people
are not following politics
okay it's just elementary right so in a
way
voting wise the turkish are offended
so they're gonna go one side this is not
an armenian message i'm just giving you
a logical mathematical
one audience is bigger in america than
ever my question was why would biden do
it
is it a misstep what i don't know if it
was a missile but he must have said look
i got a hundred days to get this done
i'm rolling out covert i'm doing
immigration reform
yeah i got to do everything with the
border we've got 15 million we've got to
get this american judgment why'd he do
it here's how typically it could be
could be as simple as
hey you want me to do this like hey
bezos
why is it the day before him voting for
union bezos goes out there and says i
support a tax increase
and then the next union didn't work on
the city state of georgia
why maybe something was happening there
i don't know
maybe somebody agreed to do three other
uh
favors for him but the one favorite he
has to give in return is to make sure
the armenian you don't know what's going
on behind closed doors
there's 50 different things on the table
to negotiate you give me this i give you
this
it's like exchanging cards and monopoly
you give me electric
i'll give you utilities i'll give you a
railway i'll give you this atlantic you
give me boardwalk
for these three prop i'll give you
illinois there's 50 pieces behind closed
doors that are being negotiated right
now you just don't know what those
negotiations
it's not like it's public so this may
have been one of those things in there
that he just had to go out and make an
announcement of
we will never know do you think this
might just be
me being naive or just me a nice little
soy boy over here
do you think that he actually did it
because it was just the right thing no i
don't think so
it was it happened i don't think a
million people were murdered there's a
genocide it was a massacre i think so
and i have very strong opinions i think
it's the right thing
i don't think he has no i don't think so
because i think obama would would have
done it i think obama was a nice guy
i don't think so because i think bush
would have done it he's a pretty nice
guy
i i don't i don't think it's that factor
i just think
there's other things we don't know about
and maybe we'll
never know about until somebody writes
about it in their book like a jim baker
that we'll read about 20 30 years from
now okay
just like you know the movie argo came
out when 30 years after what happened at
the event you can't do the movie because
cia rules what 30 years
so certain things we're not going to
know for i think it's 30 years
certain things we're not going to know
for a long time as an armenian
very happy for you you're at least
thankful yeah 100 i made a video about
it it's not about if i'm thankful i
i applauded him for making this decision
and i said thank you i think it's a
great thing that took place
just a side note on reparations 1.3
billion was paid from america to native
american tribes between 1946 and 1978.
1.6 billion paid to japanese from
america in 1988 there you go
but over 90 billion was paid to germany
uh and distribute over uh 91.9 billion
dollars to the jewish
victims of holocaust so this is actually
you know extrapolating
quartz.com but that's a response to
erdogan what he just said so what
erdogan erdogan's saying the fact that
we did pay reparations so yes we did it
we claimed it we addressed it and we're
paying for it
a lot of these casinos that are on their
land you have to pay
them by the way our pocahontas what's
her name elizabeth warren
was able to get college scholarship
because she said she's what native
american native american which is one
one thousand
native american so which means a lot of
our colleges and scholarships support
native americans right america has done
that to support them because they know
they banned up to what they did right
okay great so now erdogan
since your misstep somebody in politics
needs to go out and tweet out and give
these stats to say hey
here's what really happened so next time
you make a claim like that to your
people make sure you know the data on
what america did
to support them they screwed up and they
came back said we're sorry here's what
we're doing to make up for it so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]